>>Male Presenter: Hello everyone, thank you
guys for coming.
I'm very happy and very proud to welcome Jonah
Lehrer who is the author of three books, 'How
We Decide', 'Proust Was a Neuroscientist'
and most recently 'Imagine', which is about
the science behind creativity.
Hopefully you all will have a chance to read
it after this with the free copies.
But I think it's particularly applicable to
us because it talks about what some of the
scientific underpinnings are both at an individual
level and an organizational level in terms
of fostering creativity, what are some of
the blocks and what are some of the enablers
behind them.
So, with that, I will hand over to Mr. Lehrer
and we'll have time for a Q&A session afterwards.
>>Jonah Lehrer: Thank you all for coming.
It's a pleasure to be back at Google, I was
just at the New York office a couple weeks
ago and every time I'm in a Google office
I always get the intense urge to apply for
a job here.
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: Cause it always smells so
good and the offices are so beautiful.
Um, I don't want to step in that.
I'd like to begin today with a story about
Bob Dylan.
We heard when I walked into the room one of
his better songs playing.
So, it takes place in the early summer of
1965 when Dylan was just finishing up his
tour of England.
It'd been a grueling few months for the singer
as he had been struggling to maintain a nonstop
performance schedule.
He'd first traveled across the Northeast on
a bus playing in small college towns and big
city theaters.
Then he crossed over the west coast to the
states and crammed in a hectic few weeks of
concerts and promotion.
He'd been paraded in front of the press and
asked an endless series of inane questions
from, "What is the truth" to "Why is there
a cat on the cover of your last album?"
When Dylan wasn't surly, he was often sarcastic,
telling journalists he collected monkey wrenches,
was born in Mexico, that his songs were inspired
by chaos, watermelon and clocks.
That last line almost made him smile.
By the time Dylan arrived in London it was
clear the tour was taking a toll, the singer
was skinny from insomnia and pills, his nails
were yellow from nicotine and his skin had
a ghostly pale pallor.
Joan Baez said he looked like an underfed
angel.
He rare--, for the first time his solo shows
felt formulaic as if he were singing the lines
of someone else.
He rarely acknowledged the audience or paused
between songs, he seemed to be in a hurry
to get off stage.
Before long, it all became too much.
While touring in England Dylan decided that
he was leading an impossible life.
The only talent he cared about, his ceaseless
creativity was being ruined by fame.
The breaking point probably came after a brief
vacation in Portugal where Dylan came down
with a vicious case of food poisoning.
The illness forced him to stay in bed for
a week, giving the singer a rare chance to
reflect.
"I realized I was very drained" Dylan would
later say, "I was playing a lot of songs I
didn't want to play.
I was singing words I didn't really want to
sing.
It's very tiring having other people tell
you how much they dig you if you yourself
don't dig you."
The last shows were in London.
It was here that Dylan told his manager that
he was quitting the music business.
He was finished with singing and song writing.
He was gonna move to a tiny cabin in Woodstock,
New York.
Although Dylan had become a pop icon, the
prophetic poet of his generation, he was ready
to renounce it all.
He just wanted to be left alone.
Dylan wasn't bluffing.
As promised he returned from his British tour
and rode his Triumph motorcycle straight out
of New York City; he didn't even bring his
guitar.
Of course our story doesn't end here.
Bob Dylan did not retire in 1965.
After a few relaxing days in Woodstock, just
when he was most determined to stop creating
music, he was overcome with the familiar feeling.
"It's hard thing to describe," Dylan would
later remember.
"It's just a sense that you've got something
to say."
So Dylan did the only thing he knew how to
do, he grabbed a pencil and pad of paper and
started to scribble.
Once Dylan began his hand didn't stop for
the next several hours.
"I found myself writing this song, this story,
this long piece of vomit.
20 pages long," Dylan said, "I'd never written
anything like that before and it suddenly
came to me that this is what I should do."
Vomit is the essential word here.
Dylan is describing with characteristic vividness,
the uncontrollable rush of creative insight,
that flow of associations that can't be held
back.
"I don't know where my songs come from," Dylan
said, "It's like a ghost is writing the song.
It gives you the song and it goes away, you
don't know what it means."
In retrospect, we can see that this frantic
composition, these words written by the ghost
in Woodstock allowed Dylan to fully express
for the very first time the full diversity
of his influences.
In his cryptic lyrics, we can hear his mental
blender at work as he mixes together scraps
of Blake, Fellini, Woody Guthrie and Robert
Johnson.
Songs are modernist and pre modern, avant
garde and country western.
What Dylan did, and this is why he's Bob Dylan,
is find the strange thread connecting these
different voices.
In those first minutes of writing, he found
a way to make something new out of this incongruous
list of influences, drawing them together
into a catchy song.
When Dylan gets to the chorus and he knows
this is the chorus as soon as he commits it
to paper, the visceral power of his words
becomes obvious.
"How does it feel without a home?
Like a complete unknown, like a rolling stone."
The following week, on June 15th, 1965, Dylan
would bring the sheaf of papers into the cramped
space of Studio A Columbia records in New
York City.
After just 4 takes, the musician's only beginning
to learn their parts, "Like a Rolling Stone"
was cut on acetate.
Those 6 minutes of raw music would revolutionize
rock and roll.
The story of "Like a Rolling Stone," the reason
I'm talking about Bob Dylan today, is because
it's a story about a moment of insight.
At times, such stories can feel like romantic
clichés, the sort of make believe breakthroughs
that happened to Archimedes in the bathtub
and Newton under the apple tree.
And yet, insights do happen, they are a genuine
mental event.
They really are responsible for the theory
of gravity and "Like a Rolling Stone."
In recent years, cognitive psychologists and
neuroscientists made some interesting progress
trying to understand these most mysterious
of mental moments in terms that there are
two defining features to moments of insight.
The first defining feature is the answer just
arrives out of the blue, arrives when we least
expect it.
So we wrote our best song, our most influential
song after we quit the singing and song writing
business.
The second defining feature is as soon as
the answer arrives, as soon as we write those
words down, we know this is the answer we've
been searching for.
That this is the solution we need.
It comes attached with this feeling of certainty,
it seems like a revelation.
So those are the two defining features of
moments of insight.
And at first glance, it's not quite clear
how one can scientifically study such things
cause you can't just put undergraduates in
a brain scanner, fMRI machine and say, "Have
an epiphany we're ready for you."
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: That'd be very inefficient.
So, instead, what scientists had to do is
come up with a way to generate lots of moments
of insight on the fly.
And I'm talking today, primarily, about the
research of Mark Beeman at Northwestern and
John Kounios at Drexel University.
And they came up with a set of word problems
called compound remote associate problems.
The acronym has been unfortunate, C-R-A-P.
But they generated lots of moments of insight.
So the problems go like this, I'm gonna give
you three words, you have to find a fourth
word that can form a compound word with these
three words.
So we'll do the first one together.
The three words are pine, crab and sauce,
the fourth word in this case is apple; pineapple,
crab apple, applesauce.
Here's one for you guys.
The three words are age, mile and sand.
What's the fourth word that can form a compound
word with age, mile and sand?
>>male audience member: stone.
>>Jonah Lehrer: An answer that quick is most
certainly a moment of insight.
The answer is stone, stone age, milestone
and sandstone.
So the first thing Beeman and Kounios discovered
when they gave people these compound remote
associate problems inside an fMRI machine
is that in the seconds before the insight
appeared an obscure part of the brain called
the anterior superior temporal gyrus in the
back of the right hemisphere just behind your
ear, showed a sharp spike in activity.
It's a brain area nobody knows too much about.
It's been previously associated with things
like the processing of jokes and the interpretation
of metaphors.
And this begins to make a little sense, right?
When Romeo says that Juliet is the sun, we
know he's not saying that Juliet is a big
flaming ball of plasma gas, we realize he's
trafficking metaphor.
And how we make sense of that metaphor is
by looking past all the surface dissimilarities.
The fact that Juliet and suns have literally
nothing in common and, instead, searching
for the underlying themes it actually shares.
We're able to realize that Romeo is saying
Juliet lights up his world the way the sun
lights up ours.
Now a similar process is unfolding when you
need to make sense of pine, crab and sauce.
Those aren't three words that go together
very frequently, you've probably never used
them in a sentence before, yet this one brain
area, the anterior superior temporal gyrus,
seems to be particularly good at finding the
thin thread that binds them together.
[Laughter]
>>male offstage: they're at the other office
>>Jonah Lehrer: Oh!
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: 21st century is amazing.
>>Jonah Lehrer: So it's able to find the one
other word that binds them all together
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: Oh no, our friends, what happened?
Oh they're still happening.
Oh, that's too bad.
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: So it's able to find the one
other word that binds them all together.
Now when you need a moment of insight, when
you're stuck and stumped, when you don't know
what to do next, when you've just reached
that block, chances are you also need to draw
together a set of distantly related ideas.
If the connections were on the surface, if
they were literal, if they were obvious, you
would have found them already.
The fact that you need an epiphany suggests
that they're hidden and you need to draw together
a set of remote associations.
And that's what this one brain are, the anterior
superior temporal gyrus, seems to be so good
at.
Just the first that Beeman and Kounios discovered,
second is found to be a bit more interesting.
This they discovered when they hooked people
up to an EEG, it's like wearing a big bulky
shower cap that measures the waves of electricity
pouring out of your head.
What they discovered is they could predict
up to 8 seconds in advance whether or not
someone was gonna have a moment of insight.
Now, just think how spooky this is.
They could look at your brain waves.
They could say, "Sorry, buddy, you could sit
here all day trying to solve these word problems
and you would get nowhere.
You're wasting your time, go home."
Or they could say, "You know what, in about
7 and a half seconds you're gonna have an
epiphany so brace yourself."
The question, of course, of what this predictive
signal is, turns out to be something called
alpha waves.
Like most things in the mind, alpha waves
are pretty mysterious but they are closely
associated with states of relaxation.
So, things that lead to the production of
lots of alpha waves are things like taking
a walk on the beach, having a beer on the
couch, taking a long hot shower, playing foosball,
whatever it is that gets you to stop thinking
about those problems at work that you just
can't solve, that puts your mind at ease,
that allows you to daydream without constantly
being interrupted, that's probably a place
that's gonna generate lots of alpha waves.
Now, the reason these states of relaxation
are so important, Beeman and Kounios argue,
is when we're not relaxed, when we're focused,
when we're juiced on caffeine, when we're
chained to our desk, staring at our computer
screen, working late at the office, that's
where our attention is.
It's out in the world, we are consumed by
the noise, we are thinking about pine, crab
and sauce.
Pine, crab and sauce and inspire a wrong answer,
a common wrong answer for pine, crab and sauce
is tree, that we just can't get past.
And so we're frustrated, we're stuck, we're
making no progress.
That's why [inaudible] were in the warm shower,
shampooing our hair, unable to check our email,
that at long last we're able to turn the spot
light of attention inwards and that's when
we're able to hear that quite voice coming
from the back of our head telling us, "the
answer is apple", "the answer is apple."
Maybe that voice has been there for hours
or days or weeks, we just haven't taken a
moment to listen.
Beeman and Kounios tell this wonderful story
about this trained Tibetan Buddhist monk who,
this guy meditates 12 hours a day, so he's
got exquisite control over the spotlight of
his attention, and at first, he thought the
way to solve these compound association problems
was to stay very focused.
He'd think about pine, crab and sauce and
of course that's the wrong approach, so he
went 0 for 30.
Normally he's prompted about a twenty percent
success rate, but he was going 0 for 30 cause
he was just really, really focused.
And then at a certain point he realized, "You
know, I'm using the wrong strategy, maybe
I should switch it up."
And because he's a trained mediator he's able
to-
[Snapping]
>>Jonah Lehrer: increase his alpha waves like
that, on a dime.
And they watch this abrupt spike in his brain
waves and then he became an insight machine.
He solved 25 in a row, a streak they had never
seen before or since.
That's because he was focused on not being
focused.
Now there is something counterintuitive about
this work, right?
I think we all assume on giving a hard problem
that what we should do is work harder, pay
more attention to it, chug that Red Bull,
snort that Ritalin, do whatever it is that
we need to do
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: to maintain our attention.
But this research suggests that's the exact
wrong thing to do.
That we will be focused but we will be focused
on the wrong answer.
The next time you need a moment of insight
you should take a break, take a warm shower,
play an extended game of foosball or ping
pong, find a way to get relaxed, the answer
will only arrive after you stop looking for
it.
There's a wonderful line of Einstein's that,
"creativity is the residue of wasted time,"
The next time you need a moment of insight
you have to make time to waste time.
Now it would be wonderful if I could stand
up here and tell you that the way to solve
every creative problem is to, you know, take
a nap, get drunk.
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: Just last month a study came
out showing that when you get undergraduates
legally drunk, so too drunk to drive a car,
it's a study out of the University of, University
of Illinois at Chicago, they solved 30 percent
more difficult creative problems, that require
moments of insight, than their sober classmates.
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: So being drunk does make us
more likely to have a moment of insight and
it'd be wonderful if we could always walk
around in a stupor.
But, of course, we know that's not the case.
In the real world sometimes you have to put
in the work, sometimes you have to invest
the attention that, yes, creativity involves
inspiration, but it also involves a hell of
a lot of perspiration.
And sure enough when you talk to creative
people they often begin by telling you this
romantic story about that epiphany in the
shower but then if you keep on pressing them
they'll talk about all the hard work that
came after.
Even after they had their big idea, they still
had to edit it and refine it and make it,
you know, good enough for the real world.
As Nietzsche once observed, "Creators have
a vested interest in our believing in the
flash of revelation, the so called inspiration
shining down from the heavens as a ray of
grace, but this is often a lie.
In reality, all great artists and thinkers
are great workers."
To illustrate his point Nietzsche described
Beethoven's musical notebooks which documented
the composer's pain staking process of refining
his melodies.
It wasn't uncommon for Beethoven to experiment
with 70 different versions of a single musical
phrase before settling on the final one.
The lesson here is that even Beethoven, the
cliché of artistic genius, still needed to
constantly refine his ideas, struggling with
his music until the beauty shown through.
Let's not sugarcoat this rejecting process,
you know, the work process of Beethoven, it's
not fun.
It's the red pen on the page in a discarded
sketch, the trash prototype and the failed
first draft.
Nevertheless, such a merciless process is
sometimes the only way forward.
We keep on thinking and paying attention because
our next thought might be the answer.
So what defines this kind of creativity?
What allows some people to go through 70 different
iterations of a single musical phrase?
At first glance, it's not quite clear.
I mean, you can look at these epic successful
creators, people like Beethoven, like Bob
Dylan, like Pablo Picasso, like Steve Jobs
and ask, "Well, what makes them different
from you and me?
What makes them so successful?"
And you give them a battery of intelligence
tests and IQ tests and so on, and they'll
all look pretty normal.
They're not smarter than normal, they're often
not smarter than the rest of us.
You give them a battery of old fashioned personality
test, Myers Briggs and all the rest, and once
again, they'll look pretty standard.
Maybe a little more open to experiences and
a touch more extroverted but nothing too out
of the standard range.
But in recent years, it's become clear that
these people are different from you and me.
And there's one character, a new character
trait that sets them apart.
It's the character trait called grit.
G-R-I-T, it's about stubbornness, it's about
persistence, it's about single mindedness.
And I'm thinking here of someone like J.K.
Rowling who suffered through 12 rejections
from publishers but kept on writing about
this boy wizard in coffee shops while her
baby daughter napped.
It's that kind of stubborn refusal to give
up.
This single minded focus on seeing it through,
that is grit.
The best way to explain the importance of
grit is to tell you about how it came about,
how it was first studied.
It's a story that takes place in 2005 at West
Point Military Academy and for decades West
Point had this problem.
The first 6 weeks at West Point are known
as Beast Barracks.
It's a very tough time, you get yelled at,
you get your head shaved, you get woken up
at 5:30 in the morning, you go on long runs.
And West Point had lost between 5 and 10 percent
of its first year cadets
[Snapping]
>>Jonah Lehrer: right off the bat.
In the first 6 weeks.
This is a huge problem, right, because there
are no transfer students at West Point.
So these are future leaders of army who are
just disappearing.
They didn't wanna lose them.
So West Point had searched for decades for
some metrics, some measurements that would
allow them to predict retention, to figure
out who was most likely to drop out.
They looked at SAT scores, they looked at
grades, they looked mental and physical fitness,
everything they could think of, nothing predicted
retention.
So in 2005, in desperation, they go to Angela,
say, "Can you help us?" she comes up with
a short survey called the Grit O Survey.
You can take it on her website, just Google
Angela and Grit O Survey.
She asked questions in two different domains.
The first domain is how single minded are
you?
Have you always wanted to go to West Point?
Have you always wanted to work at Google?
To be a computer scientist?
To be a poet?
To be a painter?
To be an entrepreneur?
Whatever it is, is this the goal you've had
for a long time?
Number two, how do you react to the inevitable
frustrations and failures along the way?
Are they the sign that you should give up?
That this is the world telling you you're
not cut out for this goal?
Or are they a sign that you should try even
harder, that you should double down and just
give it your all?
So those are the kinds of questions she asked.
And what she discovered in 2005 is that her
short Grit O Survey, given to every cadet
at West Point on the second day at West Point,
was the first survey that allowed them to
predict retention.
They've used it every year since and it works
every single year.
Now, since 2005, Duckworth has gone to show
that in field after field, Grit is the single
best predictor of success.
So if you're trying to figure out which 12
year old is mostly likely to win the national
spelling bee, turns out it's not the smartest
ones, not the ones with the best grades, it's
the ones with the highest levels of grit.
Why?
Because grit mediates deliberate practice,
grit allows you to practice the right way,
which is not the fun way.
If you're trying to figure out who's most
likely to become a U.S. army ranger, it's
the ones with the highest levels of grit.
Which amateur golfers are most likely to make
the PGA tour in 5 years?
Not the ones with the best drives, the longest
drives, the best putts, it's the ones with
the highest levels of grit.
Which teachers are mostly likely to make it
through an intercity school for the first
year, the ones with the highest levels of
grit?
Which graduates of Wharton Business School
are gonna make the most money 3 years from
now.
The ones with the highest levels of grit.
That in field after field, grit explains,
above and beyond, what intelligence and IQ
scores explain.
Now I would argue, and Duckworth would agree,
that grit is particularly important in creative
domains and that's because creativity by definition
in the 21st century is gonna be hard.
If it were easy that product would already
exist, that patent would have been filed,
that poem would have been written.
So it's always gonna involve lots of frustration,
lots of failure, lots of iteration, lots of
people telling you you're not cut out for
this, this will never work, here's all the
reasons why this is a bad idea.
In order to make it real, in order to make
this idea become a tangible thing, you're
gonna have to persist through all those naysayers,
all that negative feedback and that takes
grit.
Woody Allen has this wonderful quote that,
"80 percent of success is just showing up"
well, grit is what allows you to show up again
and again.
So far I've been attempting to describe these
two distinct forms of creativity which depend
on very distinct patterns of activity in the
brain.
The more practical lesson though, is that
different kinds of creative problems benefit
from different kinds of creative thinking.
The question, of course, is how do we adjust
our thought process to the task at hand?
When should we daydream and take warm showers?
And when should we drink another cup of coffee?
What requires relaxation and what requires
grit?
The good news, and this is very good news,
the human mind has a natural ability to diagnose
our problems, to assess the kind of creativity
we need.
These assessments have an eloquent name, they're
called, feelings of knowing.
And they occur whenever we suspect that we
can find the answer if only we keep on thinking
about the question.
My favorite examples of feelings of knowing
is when a word is on the tip of your tongue.
On the one hand, so annoying, drives me crazy
every single time, you know, you're walking
down the street, you see someone, you know
you know their name but you just can't quite
place it.
So frustrating, but it's also kind of profound
because how do you know you know their name
if you don't actually know it?
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: Why are you so convinced that
memories in one of these overstuffed filing
cabinets if you can't find the file?
Well, that's a feeling of knowing.
It's a hunch reminding you that if you just
keep on searching for that name, in 5 minutes
or 10 minutes, you will find it, you will
locate the file.
That feeling of knowing will become real will
become actual knowledge.
Now, when it becomes to creative problem solving,
these feelings of knowing turn out to be an
essential guide because study after study
has found that when it comes to problems that
don't require moments of insight, that people
can actually diagnose, about 85 percent of
the time, whether or not they can solve a
problem within a given time frame.
So I can show you analytical creative problem
and say, "Can you solve this in an hour?
Can you solve this in a day?
Can you solve this in a week?"
With 85 percent accuracy, and upwards of 85
percent accuracy in many domains, people can
say, "Yep, I can do that, no problem."
Or, "No, I can't."
Now what makes these feelings of knowing even
more useful is they come attached with a sense
of progress.
So as you're working towards that problem,
you're able to say whether or not you're getting
closer to the answer even though you don't
know what the answer is, right?
Which is kind of wondrous.
It's like being dropped in a strange city,
you have no idea where you're supposed to
be going, yet you're able to say, "If I make
this left hand turn, I'm getting closer.
If I go right, I'm going a little further
away."
We're able to measure progress towards a destination
when we don't know what the destination is.
Now, I think we can use these feelings of
knowing to help us diagnose our creative problems,
then figure out, you know, should we drink
a beer or drink a triple espresso.
So, when we don't feel that we're getting
closer to the answer, we've hit the wall,
so to speak, there is no feeling of knowing,
no sense of progress, then we probably need
a moment of insight.
Maybe we've had a sense of progress before,
maybe we've been working on this problem for
a month and we've gotten closer but now we
are stuck and stumped.
Now we are Bob Dylan in May 1965.
In these instances we should rely on the right
hemisphere which excels at revealing those
remote associations.
Focusing on the problem will be a waste of
mental resources.
We will stare at our computer screen and repeat
our failures.
Instead, we should find a way to relax.
The most productive thing we can do is forget
all about work.
However, when those feelings of knowing are
telling us we're getting closer, then we need
to keep on struggling.
We should keep paying attention until it hurts,
to rely on those muscles of grit.
Before long, that feeling of knowing will
lead us to the actual answer.
So far, I've been talking about individual
creativity, about how we invent when we're
alone, but I'll spend our remaining time talking
about creative collaborations because this
form of creativity is definitely becoming
more important.
The increasing necessity of creative collaborations
is probably best demonstrated by the work
of Ben Jones, an economist in Northwestern.
He's data mined 20 million science papers,
published over the course of the 20th century.
When you go back to 1950 the most important
papers in a field, those papers with more
than 100 citations, are almost always the
product of a scientist working by themselves.
Some lone genius who managed to shift the
paradigm all alone, you know, Einstein, Darwin,
someone like that.
You fast forward, though, to the 21st century
and now science looks very different.
Now the most important papers in a field are
almost always the product of a team, of people
from different disciplines coming together.
Furthermore, the size of these teams is increasing
by about 20 percent per decade.
Jonah's explanation for this is quite simple,
our problems are getting harder, all the low
hanging fruit is gone, in fact, many of the
problems that remain exceed the capabilities
of the individual imagination.
So we either learn how to work together or
fail alone.
This raises the obvious question, how should
we work together?
What's the ideal template for group collaboration?
There's a lot to say on the subject such as
don't brainstorm, brainstorming just doesn't
work and it's important to seek out the input
of outsiders who often see more because they
know less.
But today I'd like to focus on a single theme
in successful group collaborations which is
the important of spaces that bring a diverse
mixture of people together in person.
In person being the crucial addendum.
One of my favorite examples of this is the
Pixar Studios which were largely designed
by Steve Jobs.
People at Pixar refer to them as Steve's movies.
The original plan for the studios called for
3 separate buildings, one building for the
animators, one building for the computer scientists,
one building for everyone else, the writers,
directors, producers, and so on.
Jobs, according to the legend, took one look
at these plans and said, "That is idiotic"
and tore them up in front of the architect.
He realized that the success of Pixar would
depend on all these different cultures finding
a way to collaborate.
So the animators would learn from the computer
scientists and so on.
So he said everyone should share the exact
same space.
They actually had to renovate the old Del
Monte canning factory outside of Oakland.
But Jobs realized, you know what, it's not
enough to just put people in the same building,
we need to force them to mix and mingle.
So he carved out this big atrium and he put
everything important in the atrium, he put
the mailboxes there and the gift store there
and the cafeteria there and the coffee shop
there.
And he realized, you know what, even that's
not enough cause you can build people a gleaming
cafeteria and serve delicious food but the
animators would still have lunch with the
animators, computer scientists would still
have snacks with computer scientists and so
on.
So then in one of his moments of insight,
he decided that there would only be two bathrooms
in the entire Pixar Studios
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: And he put those in the atrium.
So there's one place we all have to go every
single day, it's the bathroom.
And at first the people at Pixar thought this
was the worst idea ever, right, it's a huge
factory, it's a quarter mile long nearly,
so if you're at the wrong end of the building,
it can be a long walk to the bathroom.
But now when you spend time at Pixar you hear
again and again these stories of these bathroom
epiphanies.
The great conversation they had while washing
their hands or that serendipitous chat they
had in the hallway on the way to the bathroom.
That, as Jobs once put it, "Creativity is
just connecting things and most of those connections
come from other people."
Now, there's some neat empirical proof to
this concept.
This comes from the work of Isaac Kohane at
Harvard.
[Coughing]
>>Jonah Lehrer: He analyzed 20 thousand papers
produced by Harvard researchers.
This took him several years and a small army
of undergrads because he had to map out the
physical location of every single Harvard
coauthor down to the nearest meter.
But what he discovered is that physical location,
what he calls collocation, that it matters,
it matters a lot.
That papers produced when scientists were
within 10 meters of each other, which meant
they shared the same water cooler, the same
coffee room and the same bathroom, that those
papers were 3 times more likely to be highly
cited than papers produced when scientists
were a kilometer or more apart.
The lesson here is that even in this age of
wonderful technologies, our most important
ideas often don't arrive on a screen.
Rather they emerge from idle conversation,
from too many people sharing the same space.
Now, personally, I find this surprising.
I mean, you go back ten years and you hear
people making very convincing arguments, futurists
making these convincing arguments, that it's
the death of geography.
We live in an age where geography and physical
space are gonna become obsolete.
Why should we all move to London?
Why should we cram ourselves into these expensive,
overcrowded, smelly, crime ridden places full
of traffic and too many strangers?
What's the possible value of that?
Why should we even come to an office, why
not just sit at home in our pajamas in the
suburbs and telecommute?
It's so much easier.
It's so much more efficient.
Needless to say, that hasn't happened.
If anything, the opposite has happened.
Cities are more valuable than ever before,
more and more people are moving to cities.
Urbanization is the great theme of the 21st
century.
That in the next 100 years more people will
move to cities than have moved to cities in
all of human history.
So this is a huge and growing trend.
One of my favorite factoids is that since
the invention of Skype, attendance at business
conferences has nearly doubled.
That even though we live in this age that,
in theory, we could sit at home and get the
same content just on a screen, we know that
it's important to come together in person,
to rub up against strangers, to have those
random chats.
And I don't mean this is any way to dismiss
the importance of these new tools, you know,
to dismiss the importance of all these wonderful
gadgets.
To be able to search for anything on Google
on this phone in my pocket, that is an amazing
thing.
But these tools, they tend to make our lives
more efficient, they make it so much easier
to find stuff.
But creativity, when you look at it, it's
not really about efficiency.
It's about serendipity.
It's about encountering that information you
didn't even know to look for, about bumping
into that person you didn't even know to meet,
that, even in the 21st century, it is still
the human friction that makes the sparks.
The last idea I'd like to end with is a provocative
one and I think it's especially provocative
for a company like Google with such an incredibly
rich history of innovation.
And it speaks, I think, to the difficulty
of maintaining this pace of creativity.
In fact, it suggests that many of the things
typical companies do with the best of intentions
to make their workers more creative, actually
get in the way.
This is best demonstrated by the work of Geoffrey
West, he's a theoretical physicist at the
Santa Fe Institute.
He studies cities and gathers vast tracks
of data from governments from all across the
world trying to understand what makes cities
tick and why some cities tick better than
others.
He's done all sorts of peculiar correlations.
One of my favorites is that when you're trying
to find the most predictive variable of patents
per capita in a given metropolis, it turns
out to be the walking speed of pedestrians.
First of all, who knew the census bureau in
the states collected data on the walking speed
of pedestrians.
But, that's bizarre enough, but nobody knows
what to make of this correlation.
It could be a random accident, it could be
just a statistical fluke, but West argues
that it begins to make sense.
The function of a city is to foster those
bumps, to get people to just have those random
interactions while waiting in line for a latte,
on the sidewalk, so in a sense people are
particles.
You can model urban dwellers as particles.
And if you increase the velocity of those
particle, you make those pedestrians walk
just a bit faster, you get more bumps and
eventually those bumps add up and you get
a new patent.
But, West makes this very interesting comparison
between cities and companies.
He points out that from a certain perspective,
cities and companies look quite similar, right?
They're both big clusters of people in a fixed
physical space, lots of infrastructure, yet
cities and companies exhibit one very interesting
difference.
That cities, this form of social organization
we call cities, they never die.
They are immortal.
You can nuke a city, comes back.
You can flood a city, bounces back.
You can have a devastating earthquake, burn
the city to the ground and we still have San
Francisco.
Companies, on the other hand, die all the
time.
They are incredibly fragile.
Fortune 100 firms, these huge multinational
firms, their average lifespan is 45 years.
Only two companies in the original Dow Jones
index are still around.
More than 25 percent of Fortune 500 firms
die every decade.
So West wanted to understand, what's the difference,
why are cities immortal, resilient and perdurable?
Why are companies so fragile and fleeting?
Well, by analyzing lots and lots of data he
found an interesting difference and the difference
is this.
As cities get bigger everyone in that city
becomes more productive, by every metric we
have, they're gonna look better, they're gonna
make more money, invent more patents, invent
more trademarks and so on.
This is the trend, in fact, that's making
our cities bigger.
This is what's driving urbanization; it's
called superlinear scaling.
So urban productivity looks like this, like
a roller coaster taking off into the sky.
This is why West calls cities the most important
invention in the history of human civilization,
the idea that's unleashed so many of our ideas.
You get this social multiplier effect in the
cities.
Companies, on the other hand, look very different.
As a company gets bigger, everyone in that
company becomes less productive.
They bring in less profit per employee, fewer
patents per employee, fewer trademarks and
so on.
This is called sublinear scaling.
So companies look like this and over time
this becomes a dangerous trend, right, because
Wall Street there's all this pressure to keep
on getting bigger to grow the bottom lines.
That's what companies do.
But that means you've got expanded bureaucracy,
expanded fixed cost, but you're no longer
innovating at the same rate.
So you become more reliant on your old ideas
for your new ideas, you have an expense of
expensive acquisitions.
But eventually, those old ideas are no longer
useful, those acquisitions don't pan out and
that's when you go belly up.
Now what causes the difference, why are cities
superlinear and companies are sublinear?
West argues it's because companies get in
the way.
When you think about a city, the magic of
a city is no one's in charge.
It's a freewheeling chaotic place and a mayor's
a pretty powerless figure.
He can't tell you where to live or who to
talk to or what to work on.
It's just a bunch of particles, a bunch of
strangers going about their business, bumping
into each other.
That because cities don't try to maximize
creativity, that's exactly what they end up
doing.
Companies, on the other hand, try to micromanage
the process.
So, they tell us who to talk to, they tell
us what to work on, you know, brainstorm,
they tell us don't drink a beer in the afternoon,
focus, focus, focus.
They stifle horizontal interactions becoming
these very vertical places; they silo knowledge
and so on.
And in all these things, many of which are
done with the best of intentions, they actually
get in the way, they hold us back.
So West's advice is simple, when in doubt
imitate the city.
In closing, the imagination has always seemed
like a magic trick of matter which is probably
why we've always blamed our best ideas on
the muses.
The good news, that by finally understanding
where our new ideas come from, we can hopefully
have a few more of them.
The science of creativity can make us just
a little bit more creative.
But we must also be honest.
The creative process will never be easy no
matter how much we know about neurons or cities.
The science of the imagination doesn't fit
neatly on a Power Point slide and it can't
be summarized in a subtitle.
If creativity were that easy, Picasso wouldn't
be so famous and it wouldn't require so much
grit.
It's about all of the clever studies and rigorous
experiments our most essential talent remains
our most mysterious.
The mystery is this; although the imagination
is inspired by the everyday world, by its
flaws and its beauties, we are able to see
beyond our sources to imagine things that
only exist in the mind.
There was nothing, now there is something,
it's almost like magic.
Thank you all so much for having me at Google
and thank you so much for listening today.
I think we've got some time for Q and A, so
that's my favorite part, so please have at
it.
[Applause]
>>male #1: Thank you so much for that, so
it's hard to choose whether I should ask a
question on the individual side or the organizational
side; I'll go with the individual side.
Which is, when you think about alpha waves
and more about the pervasiveness of technology,
do you think those moments where we can actually
detach have now gone away because we always
have a phone in our pocket, a tablet and access
to these things?
Or is our only sanctum the shower now?
>>Jonah Lehrer: I mean, it's a really interesting
question and I always try to resist the urge
to speculate on the forwarding effects of
technology.
I think it's so easy to be scared by it or
think it's gonna change everything.
You know, Google's either making us stupid
or it's the salvation.
And I think it's complicated, I mean, like
I said, these tools are amazing.
They're allowing us to connect and expose
ourselves to information we never could have
had before.
I think they fuel our curiosity.
But, in my own life, what I can say is that
I have noticed that now when I'm bored, the
first thing I do, no matter where I am, is
I get out my phone and I check my email, I
check Twitter, I check, you know, I go to
Google News, whatever it is.
So I'm always interrupting my daydreams.
And that worries me simply because we've learned
in the last few years that day dreaming, this
mental state we've always told our kids not
to practice, we've assumed it's like this
form of thinking when we don't want to think
at all.
It turns out to be incredibly useful, that
your brain consumes more energy while day
dreaming than it does when you're focused.
And that's because huge swaths of cortex are
communicating and interacting, you're mashing
up new associations, you're exploring counter-factuals
and that's why people who daydream more score
much higher on tests of creativity.
So we now believe daydreaming is quite important.
And being bored is a precursor to daydreaming,
right, you daydream, you fall down that rabbit
hole in your own mind after you're a little
bit bored and so you entertain yourself.
So I do worry, that in my own life, these,
you know, having these computers in our pockets
does sometimes interfere with our ability
to go on these extended daydreams, that we're
always interrupting them.
So, you know, one way I've tried to compensate
for this is, you know, when I'm really stuck
and stumped at work, I'll go for a walk and
just leave my phone behind.
It makes me anxious for an hour
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: You know, to not be checking
email.
But that's kind of how I've solved it.
And I think it's, when you talk about technology
it's finding those kinds of tweaks.
In general these tools are so wonderful and
I love them so much but just finding ways
to kind of give ourselves a break from that
every once in a while.
>>male #2: Hello, you mentioned that you shouldn't
brainstorm.
I was kind of interested in that cause we
do an awful lot of that here.
>>Jonah Lehrer: Yeah, this is classic brainstorming
I'm talking about.
Classic brainstorming was invented by a guy
named Alex Osborn in the late 1940s.
He's the O in BBDO; he's kind of the Don Draper,
the star of Mad Men, of his day, very swank,
dapper fellow.
In the series of best selling business books
he outlines this technique he called, he called
brainstorming.
There's really just one important rule to
brainstorming as he described it, which is
no criticism is allowed.
That all ideas are good ideas, right?
The logic here is quite straight forward that
the imagination is meek and shy and fragile
and if it's worried about being criticized
it'll just clam up and not be able to say
anything interesting at all.
And this is a feel good productivity technique,
right?
We can all go into a room and free associate,
we fill the white board with our ideas, we
all contributed to the group, we all felt
productive, no one had their feelings hurt,
so there's a reason why people have done brainstorming
for so long.
The only problem with brainstorming is that
it just doesn't work.
That study after study over the last 60 years
has shown that people who brainstorm in a
group come up with fewer ideas, and less original
ideas, than those same people who work on
the problems by themselves.
That we become less than some of our parts
when we brainstorm and the reason brainstorming
doesn't work returns us to the very first
rule which is 'thou shall not criticize'.
Cause it turns out that criticism is really
important.
The work of Charlan Nemeth at UC Berkeley,
she's shown dozens of studies that groups
that engage in debate and dissent, where they're
encouraged to constructively criticize the
ideas of other people, they come up with anywhere
between 25 to 40 percent more ideas and those
ideas are seen as more original.
One of my favorite data points of hers is
that you ask people, you know, you have three
different conditions, one condition is brainstorming,
one condition is do whatever the hell you
want and third condition is debate and dissent.
So you ask people to work on hard problems
like reduce traffic in the San Francisco Bay
area.
Then you let them work on the problem and
then you say, "Okay we're gonna bring you
back in an hour or a day or a week."
Give them some time and when you bring them
back you ask them, "Okay, since the study
was over, have you had any more new ideas
since?"
And it turns out that those who engaged in
debate and dissent come up with, on average,
7 times more new ideas after the study is
over.
They can't stop thinking about it cause they're
more engaged, invigorated, they're more surprised.
That when we stick to our natural free associations,
when there is no debate and dissent, we kind
of float on the superficial surface and it
turns out our free associations are pretty
superficial.
You know, over the last decade, psychologists
have amasses these word association charts
and so I'm able to predict, with pretty good
accuracy, that if I ask you to free associate
on blue, your first answer will be green,
followed by ocean, sky, jeans, Smurfs, maybe
Miles Davis and so on.
But nothing too interesting, I mean, I can
predict the vast majority of your free associations.
That's because we're bound by language and
language is full of clichés.
The way we get passed that superficial surface
is with criticism.
That means we're fully engaged, we're digging
down deeper, we've got some skin in the game,
so even after the meeting is over we keep
on thinking about it.
So, we know brainstorming doesn't work, we've
got some hints as to improve it, to encourage
debate and descent but, of course, research
comes with a huge caveat which is that all
these studies are done with undergrads on
a one off basis.
You give them an experiment, they come together
and they go away and they never see each other
again.
In a work place you're dealing with colleagues
who come together every single day.
And it's unclear how to actually implement
debate and dissent.
You see at Pixar where they're already struggling
with it, every day there begins with what
they call the shredding meeting.
Which is where they review the few seconds
of footage from the day before and they tear
it apart, they dissect it.
It sometimes, as Jobs put it, involves brutal
honesty but I'm not sure that would work for
every place.
So I think it's still unclear how to actually
translate debate and dissent to a collegial
work environment.
To make sure it's constructive, to make sure
it's, you know, remains positive and it remains
productive.
Cause the last thing you want, obviously,
is for people just going at it and getting
personal and getting nasty.
But what we can say now, I think with some
fairly good certainty, is that brainstorming
just doesn't work.
That it's time to find ways to experiment
with debate and dissent.
>>female #1: Along the lines of inspiration,
could you tell the story of your favorite,
how you came up with the idea of one of your
three books?
>>Jonah Lehrer: Um, that's interesting, it
sounds so grandiose to talk about my own ideas
in terms of epiphanies especially after having
just described "Like a Rolling Stone" that's
quite intimidating.
My first book really emerged from, I was working
in a neuroscience lab at the time and we were
studying memory, the chemistry of memory.
>>Jonah Lehrer: And basically what that meant
was you poke a sea slug over and over and
over again until it gets bored by your touch.
So it adapts, habituates, to the touch.
And that's a form of memory and you can pull
out its neurons and figure out what, you know,
the chemistry with a long term potentiation
is.
Not most people think of it as a memory but
it was that kind of work.
I mean very reductionist neuroscience.
At the time, by sure accidents, I was taking
a course in French modernism.
So, we were assigned Proust and I was reading
Swann's Way and his first volume of the epic
and that's really a novel all about memory.
It's all about long term storage of memories.
I mean, it's this novelist who famously dips
his Madeleine, this buttery sea shell shaped
cookie, into a lime floured tea and all of
a sudden he remembers all these memories from
his childhood that he'd thought he forgot.
And they all come flooding back to him triggered
by this scent of this childhood cookie.
And so that got me thinking about here's this
novelist describing this very rich, very detailed
memory and, in particular, how these memories
are triggered by the smell and taste of things.
And at the time Proust had no idea how the
brain actually worked.
There wasn't a whole lot of neuroanatomy and
yet, in the last decade, neuroscientists have
come along and figured out that the reason
why, it's not called the Proust effect, why
our smells and tastes are more sentimental.
And that's because the olfactory cortex, the
part of the brain that processes smells and
tastes, is the only sensory area directly
connected to the hippocampus, the center of
long term memory.
This is really an accident of evolution, it's
just cause for most primitive species, smell
and taste are really, really important.
We're more visual but this wire had never
been cut.
And, so, even though Proust didn't know about
neuroanatomy, somehow he was able to intuit
these wires and he was able to realize that,
yes, smell and taste are uniquely nostalgic.
And so I was reading that literally in the
lab.
And probably just because of where I was,
I was thinking about this novel and these
silly scientific terms and that's where I
had the idea for my first book which is all
about the intuitions of artists and how sometimes
they, they presage the discoveries in modern
neuroscience.
I wasn't in a shower or anything.
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: I was actually quite bored.
I was waiting for an experiment that I'd been
trying to run for a month and it never worked
and it turns out if actually never worked.
And I kind of knew it would never actually
work so that's why I was passing the time
in the lab reading a novel, so maybe my alpha
waves were going.
But I don't know.
Thanks for the question.
>>male #2: Hello, I don't like the phrasing
of this question but I can't think of a better
one.
Can grit be learned?
>>Jonah Lehrer: Yeah, I don't know.
>>male #2: Can we teach it to our kids?
Can we teach it to ourselves?
>>Jonah Lehrer: Yeah, um, nobody knows for
sure, no one's on the detail genetic work
to figure out the exact, you know, the exact
breakdown of heredity in terms of grit.
The presumption is that like just about every
other personality trait it's about 50/50.
50 percent nature, 50 percent nurture.
And that's good news, right?
Cause that means you can really shift the
curve.
The question, of course, is how then to shift
the curve, how actually teach grit.
Duckworth is just beginning a ten year longitudinal
study where she looks at students in the Philadelphia
District schools, public schools in the inner
city of Philadelphia and these are some sad
statistics, but 45 percent of these kids drop
out before graduation.
She's focusing on the 55 percent of kids who
stay in, who already show higher levels of
grit than those who drop out.
Of those 55 percent who stay in, 95 percent
that the longer they stay in school the worse
their test scores get, the farther they fall
behind their peers in Pennsylvania.
This is just, to me, depressed the hell out
of me, right?
The longer they are in these schools, the
worse they get.
5 percent of these kids, though, in these
same schools, in the same struggling community,
with little household support, they make themselves
better.
They find a way to improve their test scores.
So Duckworth is trying to figure out what
sets these kids apart.
Sure enough they score off the charts in grit
but she wants to figure out how does that
cash out?
What does that actually mean?
She's looking at their work habits, their
routines and so on.
She's pulled out some interesting stuff.
They tend to focus on exemplars when they're
frustrated.
So they've got a model, maybe it's a sports
star, maybe it's Martin Luther King, someone
like that who they know persevered through
difficulty and they think about them a lot,
especially when they're going through a tough
time.
So, one of the first pieces of advice is give
kids heroes, give them exemplars.
She also found some interesting stuff like
this one I didn't expect, these kids from
a certain perspective are just more thoughtless
that when they're doing their algebra homework
they're not thinking about the ball game on
TV, they're not taking the opportunity cost
of their activity, they just do the algebra
homework cause that's what they need to do.
So they're not exploring counterfactuals,
what else they could be doing, they're just
doing it.
So they think less about alternatives which
is kind of interesting.
They're more focused on tangible progress
than the long term goal.
Cause that goal is so distant that if you're
just thinking about the long term goal you'll
get demotivated very quickly.
So it's very important to think about, "Well,
I got better today.
I'm doing a little bit better today than I
was yesterday."
And so on.
But it's too early to say, I think, that these
are the 5 things you need to do to build grit
up in yourself or in your children.
Right now Duckworth's best advice is this
wonderful maxim she refers to, choose easy,
work hard, which means that we should expose
our kids and ourselves to a menu of possibilities.
To a lot of things you might fall in love
with.
Maybe it's painting, maybe it's drawing, maybe
it's computer programming, maybe it's marketing,
who knows, just let yourself find something
that feels like fun, that feels like play
not like work.
And then once you commit to it, you have to
remind yourself every single day to work hard.
To put in your ten thousand hours plus or
minus five thousand hours, that it's not always
gonna be fun, in fact, it'll rarely be fun.
People who are really gritty, they find the
un-fun stuff just as aversive as people who
don't have grit, it's just they're able to
push on through it.
So, choose easy, work hard is, I think, the
best advice we have right now.
>>female #2: Can we take a question from Daniel
in our Soho office?
[Pause]
>>Jonah Lehrer: Maybe this is why people still
go to business conferences.
[Laughter]
>>male #3: Can't hear you Daniel.
>>Jonah Lehrer: I wish I could lip read.
[Pause]
>>female #2: Okay, alright, we'll move on
with another question and we'll come back
to Daniel.
>>male #4: Hi, um, you mentioned scientists
going from working individually to working
in larger and progressively larger groups.
And you mentioned some of the scientists working
individually, Darwin and Einstein and they
had very revolutionary ideas.
I'm wondering if the move to groups will lead
to more evolutionary science as opposed to
revolutionary science where if the ideas of
energy as matter would get thrown out in a
debate early on in a group?
>>Jonah Lehrer: It's a really interesting
question and it's something I've talked with
Jones about extensively.
And I think it's unclear to him whether or
not, I think, I feel like physics if it's
just too immature to still have those kinds
of total paradigm shifts or if we now know
enough about the structure of reality where
it's just become an evolutionary science.
Yes?
>>male #4: The same was thought before Einstein
>>Jonah Lehrer: Of course, in 1903
>>male #4: They've become a scientist, we
know everything.
>>Jonah Lehrer: Of course, they've been saying
that, I'm sure Pythagoras was complaining
about, ugh, all the interesting problems have
been solved.
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: It's a refrain you see again
and again but eventually it's gonna be true,
right?
Eventually we will have a good enough map
of reality where, you know, our predictions
line up.
And, you know, I think it's unclear with all
these super colliders coming out online, if,
you know how much they'll change about our
assumptions.
So, I think there are many, many interesting
problems to solve in a field like physics,
in a field like neuroscience, the answers
even more clear that we know nothing.
That right now we know enough just to know
how little we actually understand.
Um, so I think there's absolutely revolutions
waiting to happen.
I don't think, necessarily, that teams, by
definition, will make those paradigm shifts
less radical.
I mean, I think that's our old model of big
paradigm shifts come from individuals.
I think Jones would argue it's just now we
need to be more interdisciplinary.
When you look at a field like neuroscience,
which I know better that physics, unfortunately,
and you look at the kinds of problems we need
to solve, they require people with backgrounds
in, you know, like the Connectum, it's a big
movement neuroscience to understand the actual
wiring diagram of the brain.
That requires people with backgrounds in computer
science, computer programming, you know, molecular
biology, neuroscience, neurology, I mean,
it requires all these different people to
come together.
No single field, no single discipline can
solve it by themselves.
And what Jones argues is there simply are
limits to how much knowledge the brain can
hold.
It takes ten years to even amass an expertise
in one of those disciplines.
We don't live long enough to become an expert
in enough disciplines to actually tackle these
very, very hard problems which is why they
exceed our individual capabilities.
But it's an interesting question.
I think there's no good answer for it yet.
I think we'll have to see how 21st century
science plays out.
>>female #3: Hello, um, I really enjoyed all
your radio lab contributions.
>>Jonah Lehrer: Oh, thank you.
>>female #3: And I wanted to ask you, cause
there was an article in the New York Times
last Sunday about the brain and physical activity.
I wanted to see if you can quote any studies
on daydreaming and making all these connections
with physical exercise.
Thank you.
>>Jonah Lehrer: It's interesting, I mean,
a lot of people, it turns out physical activity
when it comes to like daydreaming and alpha
waves whether or not it's relaxing, it's very
divisive.
Some people, and people in these studies,
some people find going to the gym very relaxing.
They find the Stairmaster or the Treadmill
or jogging outside, very relaxing.
They'll talk about all the great ideas they
have when they jog.
Some people find it very stressful.
So that's why it's tough, in general, to come
up with a universal prescription for how to
relax yourself.
Maybe it's playing football, maybe it's playing
foosball.
It's different for everybody and that's why
it's so important for each individual to seek
out their own place that puts them at ease.
I mean, on the larger subject of physical
exertion, it's so essential.
And I think it's been one of the big themes
in modern neuroscience, which has surprised
neuroscience, cause I think for a long time
we like to flatter ourselves by thinking about
the brain as somehow separate from the body,
you know, just, we're just this, you know,
ethereal brain in a vat, mostly un tethered
and disconnected from this fleshly machine
we gotta carry around.
Well, it turns out that's not true at all.
That's why neurogenesis, for instance, the
birth of new brain cells in, you know, even
the adult brain, is very closely connected
with physical exercise.
The single best way to increase neurogenesis
is to get more exercise, to move about more.
You see this is rodents and you see this in
humans.
Nobody knows why that is but we know it's
just, it's important.
Some new studies have come out looking at
dementia and blood flow and simply blood flow
to the brain increases with exercise.
It's improving your cardiovascular system
and so one of the best ways to save off dementia
seems to be even better than playing bridge
every day which used to be like the best prescription,
is going for a walk, getting exercise, getting
your blood going.
Now one of the control studies, which I'm
kind of fascinated to see how it turns out,
there compared exercise to people that do
headstands.
Cause if it's just about blood flow, right,
then a headstand should work pretty well.
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: So that'll be interesting,
that'll be a better test to the causality.
So, I think that's due to come out next year.
Um, I mean, right now we can say it's important,
I don't think we understand all the causal
mechanisms, that's my release on the research.
>>female #2: I think we're about running out
of time but if we could just do two more questions.
I've got one from Daniel in the Soho office.
You talked about idle conversation in the
online space and gave the example of Skype.
What's your perspective on the rise of social
and catalyzing serendipitous connections and
is there any way of transferring serendipity
into the online space?
>>Jonah Lehrer: I have no doubt there is.
I'd be the last person to ever bet against
the future innovations of tech companies.
I think it's astonishing how far we've come
in a short amount of time.
That's, I don't think we've found it yet.
I think too often the online space, our interactions,
and this is at least true with my interactions,
they're driven by what psychologists call
self-similarity principle.
Where even a platform like Twitter, which
I think could be used to foster some kind
of serendipity.
And I'm always depressed when I look at who
I follow on Twitter, it's people a lot like
me, people who are interested in the brain,
interested in science, people who are good
liberals, etcetera, etcetera.
And this is the self similarity principle.
This has been found in study after study that
it's always easier to spend time with people
who are just like us.
And so, when given a choice, we seek out those
who think like us, who talk like us, vote
for the same politicians, speak the same languages,
use the same acronyms and so on.
That's more comfortable, that's easier, less
tension.
And I think that speaks to the importance
of what cities do.
Cities bring together a bunch of weirdos and
throw us together.
We can't choose who we bump into.
And so, in a sense, I think that when you
imagine a serendipitous online space, it would
be kind of unpleasant.
It's hard to imagine how you would have serendipity.
You know, have that human friction but not
have it be so unpleasant.
Have us choose to go to a website that's gonna
say, "I'm gonna confront you with strangers
who think differently than you."
I have no doubt it'll happen cause I think
it's a really important next step, but I have
yet to come up with a good plan of how to
make it happen other than to randomly choose
people to follow on Twitter.
But I have no doubt that someday a company
like Google will come up with a way to actually
foster serendipity online, interpersonal serendipity
especially.
>> male off mic: the last one
>>female #4: Hi, very fascinating speech,
I've got a real interest in the grit thresholds
neurologically.
I'm wondering if any studies have been taken
by people with respect to, you know, these
highly focused, highly successful creative
people who have a very high level of grit
and those that also have a very high level
grit that like certain sports stars and other
people who get to that, you know, high level
of grit and then get, you know, what is characterized
as burn out, ME or chronic fatigue those sorts
of things.
How do you think that works, you know, neurologically
in the brain?
What differentiates between those two types
of people?
>>Jonah Lehrer: You mean what separates those
with lots of grit from those who?
>>female #4: Who had lots of grit but then
the grit threshold is obviously too high and
then the brain goes, "I can't take this anymore"
and shuts down.
>>Jonah Lehrer: I mean it's a great question.
There's no, no one is really taking grit to
the brain yet.
It's a brand new character trait, at least
in the context of character traits it's only
been around since 2005.
So, you know, we've got some sense of what
underlies it from lots of work on self control
cause grits in the self control family.
But it's too soon to say what exactly parts
of the brain fizzles out or kind of goes limp
when people, who clearly were able to put
in the work, just give up.
It's also important to point out that it's
not always great to just have endless grit
resources that, grit, like all character traits,
you can have too much of it.
So you get increasing returns, it gets better
and better and at a certain point you can
have too much grit, right, you can be too
single minded.
Like, I may wanna be a professional basketball
player, in fact, I do wanna be a professional
basketball player.
But someone's gotta pull me aside and say,
"You know what, even if you're the greatest
person in the world, look at yourself.
You still won't get there."
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: So if I'm too gritty, I may
devote my life to trying to accomplish an
impossible goal.
So grit is also about being a little strategic
about saying like what are the goals that
are worth pursuing given who I am?
That's why Duckworth argues we have to be
more realistic in talking to our kids.
Like, right now we say, "If you can dream
it, you can do it!
Just go for it!"
When, maybe that's kind of bad advice sometimes.
Maybe we should make sure that, I know it
sounds sad, right?
[Laughter]
>>Jonah Lehrer: It sounds so cynical but let's
be honest.
We can't all play in the NBA and that's just
the fact of life.
So we should make sure our kids, at the very
least, have some kind of tangible plan for
getting from, you know, where they are to
where they wanna be.
And maybe it'll mean just giving them better
advice at an early age.
And make sure they've got realistic goals
too.
Not that we shouldn't dream or anything, I
should be the last person to suggest that,
but that we should be realistic.
So, you know, in terms of why some people
give up, um, I think it's often that, one
explanation that I might propose is that these
are people that are actually very strategic
about goal setting.
Maybe they were a football star and they had
a lot of grit and they put in those ten thousand
hours and got really good at it but then they
realized that I'm just, you know, my talents
are fading, I'm not quite good enough, I should
find a new goal while I still can and devote
my grit to that resource.
One of the important things about grit is
the limited resource, it's a scarce resource.
So, it's a bit like self control, you have
to figure out how to allocate it depending
on what you wanna do.
So, sometimes you see people switching, a
lot of gritty people will have just one goal
for their entire life and do that, they're
able to pivot but once they pivot they're
able to commit to that goal.
So grit isn't just about stupid persistence
it's also about being strategic in how you're
single minded.
>>presenter: Unfortunately we're out of time.
>>Jonah Lehrer: Thank you.
>>presenter: I'm sure we could spend the next
few hours peppering you with questions.
But really just wanna thank you for coming
and join me in a round of applause here.
[Applause]